où pouvez-vous vous retrouver pour la célébration la plus
diabolique de tous les temps,
c'est vrai whataburger et maintenant pour un
temps limité dans le cadre de notre nouveau
menu diabolique, nous ajoutons deux 61
galettes de viande à chaque gros burger homie
vous donnant non pas un pas deux
mais trois  fois la saveur entièrement américaine,
mais nous ne nous arrêtons pas là, nous
vous donnons également encore plus de façons de devenir
diabolique lorsque vous ajoutez notre nouveau ranch
chili queso à n'importe quel sandwich ou
salade de burger en augmentant la chaleur de vos
classiques de bottaburger préférés avec un
film caliente coup de poing dans les tripes
et assurez-vous de faire tomber toute la
famille pour une super surprise car les héros de
tous âges peuvent collecter l'un des huit
jouets diaboliques dans chaque petit super
repas
wow noir noir oh j'ai un laser bébé ouais
j'ai des boules picantes alors  n'attendez pas devenez
diabolique avec vos amis et votre famille
ou venez tout seul il y a toujours
quelqu'un qui vous attend au bottaburger
affamé de quelque chose de frais
pourquoi attendre attrapez les huit à venir le
4 mars dans un lieu nea  r vous
[Musique]
vous